what's this looks like a red wire well
that wasn't here before
was a computer do I mean computers have
wires gears doesn't doesn't it no it's
going in a different direction than the
other wires right I'm really busy I
can't talk about this anymore I got 500
feet of red wire at a flea market up by
Del Mar high school 20 bucks for the
whole spool crazy what a deal
oh they'll be fine I made it up there
hey I know what would cheer you up let's
go wait outside the bathroom for Tom and
scare him that would cheer me up okay
ready
and Jerry God gross Oh Jerry guys Oh bud
well I think he might be having a heart
attack
what are you serious oh so much stuff is
happening right now call them on one
okay just breathe okay you're gonna be
fine nor jeez that a dinosaur dysphoric
Jerry get a grip sorry guys apology not
accepted
stop talking [ __ ] I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat farts for lunch
Tom Jerry's having a heart attack what
do you know that Jerry okay hey can I
talk to the captain
oh he's on the phone do you want a
coffee while you wait they made me an
extra line on accident oh sure thank you
oh my god what is that man you just
drank some man guys check back in to see
if she dies oh you're not really gonna
die probably okay just a little honey
for the G hive also you can talk to hold
he is not on the phone what is happening
it's a little something Michael do
pranks for the price of one Santiago I'm
on the phone hey hello Jim what's up
buddy this is not funny why is my stuff
in here well it's weird
ooh daughter first a boy that's pretty
good yeah well I'm not paying for my own
stuff okay I know you did this because
you're friends with the ending machine
guy who Steve yeah
oh no no no that's my pencil cup I don't
think I think so
and you're gonna hand it over to me I
love these Oh nervous j1 care you know
how many you get snickles
I probably should have said no to some
of his ideas but he's on his way here
right now here he is just be cool
hey guys what's up oh I just remembered
can I show you something out to the
front area and leave your cell phones
because if no reason just leave anything
that can't get wet actually like you
would normally okay here we go to the
parking lot now wow this is really sad
yep follow to me guys just go into the
parking lot for normal government
reasons sir he can't go through with
this I was gonna pull a prank no ya
hired these guys in ski masks to kidnap
us and I was gonna pretend to be a hero
they were gonna shoot me and drive the
van into the river and that's when the
divers would go and pull you guys out of
the water and I would be standing on the
shore like hey you get pranked much
what's up
we got these squids from a special
effects guy and I was gonna say this
code word that's what I would push this
button no good oh my god you got blood
all over me thank you I mean it Ben that
was amazing really best prank ever where
is my desk that is weird this is not
funny this is totally unprofessional
okay well you're the one who lost the
desk I didn't lose my desk okay calm
down
where was the last place you saw okay
who moved my desk I think you should
retrace your steps okay I am going to
tell Michael and this entire office will
be punished colder warmer a little
warmer Hey ooh
warmer warmer warmer warmer warmer cold
cold cold back up
Dwight Schrute
hi um what sort of discounts are we
giving on the G I've given you this
information like 20 times by the ream is
now 978 sorry it's just k7 yourself okay
thank you gotta get back to work
wash your hands Kevin oh hello yes guys
guys so check it out it's caca fell
asleep in the break room so I put his
hand in a bowl warm water
come on man that's the stupidest prank
ever ah no it's the smartest because it
involves biology I bet it worked already
let's go Jack Hitchcock no he's drowning
he's drowning baby man take it back Jake
great prank so while they repaint the
lines in the parking lot we're asking
everyone to do street parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn all right moving
on to recycling UK run just a little
tooth pain I'm fine continue okay each
department will be getting blue bins do
you need to go to the dentist
run I don't like dentists just a second
[Applause]
oh my god I'm sorry everybody what were
we talking about recycling dentist
pulled the tooth out yesterday but it's
always a good idea to demonstrate to
your co-workers that you are capable of
withstanding a tremendous amount of pain
plus it's always fun to see Tom faint
it's kind of blurry it's better question
what kind of bear is best that's a
ridiculous question
false black bear well that's debatable
there are basically two schools of
thought fact bears eat beets so bears
beets battlestar galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses $4 and it only cost me $7
to recreate the rest of the ensemble and
that's a grand total of lemon dollar you
know what imitation is the most sincere
form of flattery so I thank you any
theft is not a joke Jim millions of
families suffer every year Michael oh
that's funny
Michael Sarge I got a case for you guy
that's phone stolen at a bar last night
oh it's not that big a deal I just need
to file a police report for my insurance
company no it is a major injustice and
we're gonna set it right there's a
crappy old phone I'd rather just get a
new one but woody police and we're here
to help you shut your damn mouth tell us
what he look like
I only saw his back had a blue hoodie on
you just drank some men
you